i gave birth to my daughter at home  because i was like  [ __ ] no am i going into one of those  places  like you're gonna yeah no thank you i  imagine  right like if you empower women to  understand  that birth is their experience  of self-initiation it's their  entitlement and that they don't need  daddy medicine to manage their body for  them  all of the dangers when the body does it  wrong  and then to take the baby away and clean  that dirty baby  and vaccinate that you know broken  immune system  and blah blah blah all the rest it's  like you think about the ritual  power of that and when you get a mom  in that level of conditioning which of  course is amplified by all of the  emotions and all of that inner  pharmacopoeia of what's happening then  into the fold at that point you have her  for life  not just her her child